hey guys I'm going to talk about the
anatomy of a thorough score at ik plac
okay so a lot of times people think it's
this big clogged piece of cholesterol
that's clogging the arteries because
we're cholesterol so evil and it's it's
really bad and it's clogging arteries
we're gonna get a stroke and heart
attack right well let's take a look at
really what this plaque is did you
realize that 70 68 percent of the plaque
is fibrous plaque that's a fibrous
tissue that is collagen so we're not
against collagen right I mean like if
that's clogging your arteries you don't
see anyone against collagen like it's a
bad thing
80% of it is calcium 1% of it's called
the foam cell that's the immune cell
that's kind of golfing similar debris 7%
is white blood cells
okay that's creating the inflammatory
response and the lipids compose only 16
percent of that plaque and out of the 16
percent 74 percent is unsaturated it's
not even a cholesterol it's unsaturated
fat so this whole cholesterol being the
connected cause of your clogged artery
is totally and utterly a lie cholesterol
is a healer it's coming in after the
fact trying to heal that ulcer try to
put a bandaid on that and we're not
asking why we're just trying to lower it
assuming that it's the bad guy it's
actually the good guy okay all right
just want to give you some awareness of
that and put your comments below press
up please and yeah you'll get future
updates that's right updates I knew
there was a word press it forget it
forget it I'm done press the subscribe
button and I will keep you updated on
the future events